[Música]
nós vivemos num mundo de verbas da
educação precisa dialogar com o mundo
então a diversidade tem que estar dentro
das escolas
eu passei a vida escolar pensando sobre
o que eu aprendia pra que eu aprendo que
sentindo que isso tem na verdade eu
tinha a sensação de que quase tudo que
eu aprendia servia para fazer uma prova
quando eu tinha 15 anos estudava numa
escola convencional dessas em que os
professores não sabem nem o nosso nome
mas eu tinha uma vizinha que estudava
numa escola diferente numa escola onde
ela tinha liberdade onde existe uma
relação verdadeira com os professores
onde as artes estavam presentes onde ela
era ouvida e eu fiquei sonhando com
aquela escola
um dia eu fui até lá sozinha e eu
consegui uma bolsa e foi uma experiência
muito importante para mim ter vivenciado
enquanto estudante uma relação diferente
com educação
depois viajei bastante buscando sempre
destinos com culturas diferentes da
minha
e com isso eu aprendi que existem muitos
jeitos de se viver e que a natureza
também se apresenta de muitas formas
morei dois anos na bahia trabalhando com
comunidades quilombolas e lá eu tive uma
vivência mais profunda com a cultura
popular brasileira e eu também aprendi
que apesar das dificuldades financeiras
os principais valores da via estavam
presente quando a gente olha para a
formação sócio cultural do povo
brasileiro é fácil perceber como nós
somos fruto da diversidade como nós
somos resultado de culturas do mundo
inteiro não só
canos dos europeus donativos que estavam
aqui da mesma maneira quando a gente
olha para a natureza em especial pra mim
que moro em paraty no pé da mata
atlântica floresta com maior
biodiversidade do planeta é fácil
perceber como essa natureza tem muito a
nos ensinar mar foi grande não é mais
importante do que um arbusto
ambos são importantes para que a
natureza esteja em equilíbrio
a gente tem que reconhecer que a
diversidade é uma riqueza que
homogeneíza é simplificar a vida não é a
vida em si nós precisamos reconhecer que
os conhecimentos do mundo são infinitos
e o que chega pra nós é só uma pequena
parcela mas em contrapartida esses
conhecimentos são muito acessíveis como
diz o filósofo francês edgar morin ram
nós vivemos numa era planetária onde a
troca de conhecimentos é constante
então mais importante do que acumular
uma série de conteúdos para quem sabe um
dia usados na vida é ter criticidade
para buscar os conhecimentos e saber usá
los e quando a gente está falando da
troca de conhecimentos
a gente está falando de educação e
quando a gente fala em educação qual é o
primeiro espaço que nos vêm logo à
cabeça é a escola pra mim
a escola é a maior potência de formação
e transformação social uma vez que todo
brasileiro por lei precisa freqüentar
essa instituição a escola deve servir à
formação integral das pessoas então ela
tem que proporcionar uma conexão
verdadeira com a natureza e também
valorizar os diferentes saberes e
fazeres como diz a unesco nós precisamos
aprender a ser a conviver a fazê lo ea
conhecer bom mas essa escola
convencional essa escola
as grandes massas eu acho que as
estatísticas são claras audi ao mostrar
que essa escola precisa melhorar essa
escola precisa ser transformada e essa
escola ela vem sempre com uma promessa
de futuro na escola convencional ela
promete sempre um futuro mas que futuro
é esse
você sabe me dizer qual é o seu futuro
você sabe me dizer qual o futuro de uma
criança você sabe me dizer qual o futuro
de um grupo de crianças
você já parou para pensar que no futuro
muitas profissões que existem hoje vão
está obsoleta e tantas outras que a
gente não faz nem idéia vão surgir e
esse futuro é pensado para quem pra quê
para formar cidadãos plenos no mundo
ou será que é para melhorar o nosso
produto interno bruto
eu prefiro uma definição criada na
década de 70 pelo rei do butão que fala
da felicidade interna bruta
eu acho que a gente precisa olhar pra
isso e aí eu fico me perguntando que
habilidades eu preciso desenvolver para
ter um futuro feliz
[Música]
eu acho que a escola deve se preocupar
em dar um presente feliz bom grupo de
pessoas do qual eu faço parte especial
um grupo de amigos muito queridos e sem
eles eu não estaria aqui e certamente eu
tô falando de um processo por vou falar
de um processo coletivo
nós resolvemos sair dessa não escola
destinam lugar dessa escola que a gente
já entendeu que precisa ser transformada
e trilhar um novo caminho um caminho
ainda muito muito pouco conhecido por
nós mas que a gente acredita que faça
mais sentido para aquilo que a gente
quer ver na educação nós colocamos uma
série de idéias teóricas no papel e
depois a gente tem que ter muito
desprendimento para se libertar essas
teorias e parte com uma escola real com
as felicidades e dificuldade
dos acontecimentos concretos
eu vou falar pra vocês é preciso ter
coragem
realmente é preciso agir com o coração
pra enfrentar todos os desafios de se
seguir um novo caminho
[Música]
a nossa intenção era construir uma
escola viva uma escola que tem ação
reflexão ação na sua base uma escola que
está sempre se repensando se
transformando
mas antes de contar um pouco mais sobre
essa escola vou fazer uma pergunta pra
vocês
quem aqui já brincou numa roda de
ciranda como pensar numa roda de ciranda
onde todo mundo das mãos onde todo mundo
se olha onde ninguém é melhor do que
ninguém a ser anda tem esse poder de
unir as pessoas
na verdade a cultura popular brasileira
tem esse poder de união porque ele é
fruto da nossa diversidade às artes e à
cultura popular
elas têm esse poder de agregar mas
também de trabalhar os sentimentos as
relações
o autoconhecimento o senso crítico senso
estético bom mas voltando pra nossa roda
de ciranda é que essa roda seja
divertida
todos são importantes então nós
acreditamos no potencial de uma
comunidade decolar com diversidade de
pessoas ou seja com famílias de
diferentes realidades socioeconômicas
a nossa grande inspiração para isso é a
relação entre opressores e oprimidos
trazida por paulo freire
é como se de como se tivesse um muro
transparente na relação entre as pessoas
na vida e quando a gente resolve trazer
para uma mesma escola
famílias com diferentes realidades
socioeconômicas a gente literalmente
tira a peneira da frente do sol
a gente traz o conflito para a escola
as diferenças culturais aparecem e se
tornam uma ótima oportunidade para nós
trabalharmos a empatia
nós temos a oportunidade prática de
rever
nossos preconceitos e de valorizar as
diferenças e para que isso seja possível
é necessário um diálogo verdadeiro e
amoroso bom numa roda de ciranda ninguém
fica de fora então enxergar a
diversidade de idéias é acreditar que os
diferentes saberes são importantes
o saber fazer as artes as brincadeiras o
autoconhecimento tudo isso precisa ser
trabalhado junto ao saber acadêmico uma
roda de ciranda todos se relacionam e o
mundo sofre tanto com problemas de
relação à escola tem que se preocupar
com isso
também pensando numa roda de ciranda
qualquer um pode puxar brincadeira então
encherga a diversidade de caminhos é
reconhecer que não existe o caminho ou
melhor jeito de ensinar e aprender
cada um tem o seu melhor jeito de
ensinar e aprender e isso precisa ser
respeitado
além disso a gente sabe que a gente
aprende enquanto ensina ensino enquanto
aprende
então a aprendizagem é infinita mas como
fazer para ter a diversidade de pessoas
idéias e caminhos na prática de uma
escola
a primeira quebra de paradigma
importante que foi quando a gente
percebeu que era possível organizar um
currículo em ciclos no lugar de séries e
eu gosto muito de explicar os ciclos a
partir das séries que aquilo que a gente
conhece né a maioria de nós então é numa
série a gente tenha um período de um ano
um grupo de crianças com idades e
conhecimentos parecidos a gente tem uma
intenção de aprendizagem para aquele ano
se a média for 7 às crianças que
aprenderam pelo menos 70 por cento
daquilo elas seguem adiante no ciclo a
fragmentação do tempo de aprendizagem é
muito suavizada por que nós juntamos
várias séries em um único ciclo com
crianças
e conhecimentos diferentes cada um segue
aprendendo no seu ritmo ajudando os
colegas naquilo que são bons e recebendo
ajuda naquilo que precisam se
desenvolver
o circo dá muita liberdade pedagógica
porque a gente pode organizar a escola
com flexibilidade
olhando para o nosso contexto do momento
num ciclo a competição se transforma em
colaboração
[Música]
nós educadores junto com as crianças com
os pais com os nossos parceiros nós
estamos aprendendo na prática a realizar
projetos e pesquisas na escola e os
temas desses projetos e pesquisas são
escolhidos pelos próprios estudantes
esse é um jeito muito bacana de trazer
para a escola o que é o verdadeiro
interesse deles de fazê-los sujeito da
sua própria aprendizagem é um jeito
simples de trazer motivação pela
aprendizagem porque eu aprendo pra que
eu aprendo onde esse conhecimento está
no mundo
a criança aprende porque ela quer agir
um outro ponto importante é como a gente
avalia o desenvolvimento das crianças
eu realmente fico me perguntando se cada
um demonstra as suas aprendizagens de um
jeito e num ritmo diferente
como é que uma mesma prova pode ser
capaz de avaliar todo o mundo
nós não acreditamos em provas ou notas
as crianças aprendem continuamente elas
devem ser avaliados ao longo de todo o
seu processo
a gente acredita que o desejo de
aprender seja inato
então se existe motivação pela
aprendizagem da criança ela aprende
naturalmente e não porque ela precisa
trocar o seu conhecimento por uma nota
a nossa iniciativa está perto de
completar três anos e eu gosto muito de
comparar o desenvolvimento de uma escola
com um ser humano
a gente pensa em uma pessoa de três anos
enquanto que ela já aprendeu com a vida
enquanto que ela ainda tempo para
aprender com a vida
a nossa escola está bem nesse momento é
como se fosse uma criança pequena e
imatura que já aprendeu algumas coisas
importantes com a vida mas que
certamente tem um longo caminho de
aprendizagem pela frente
a nossa intenção é contribuir para a
formação de pessoas saudáveis livres e
autônomas ea gente sabe que esse
processo começa por nós adultos que
estamos sendo transformados com essa
vivência e é claro se extrapola para as
crianças sabendo que elas têm seu
próprio tempo de amadurecimento e
sabendo também que a liberdade é casada
com a responsabilidade
então eu estou falando de um processo
lento e gradual de longo prazo onde a
gente aprende dia-a-dia a ser
responsável pelas nossas ações e assim
nós nos tornamos livres
eu tenho muita esperança na
transformação da educação eu realmente
acredito que é possível ser feliz na
escola que é possível ter uma outra
relação um conhecimento com muito mais
significado
não existe uma receita de bolo modelo
até porque eu acredito que as escolas
precisam ser vivos precisam estar sempre
se repensando se transformando em um
país diverso como brasil cada escola
precisa pensar no seu contexto quem são
os estudantes seus educadores economia
meio ambiente cultura que conhecimentos
são importantes para a sua comunidade da
educação dialogue com a vida mas
sobretudo a gente tem que está muito
aberto a desconstruir muita coisa e re
aprender novas formas de lidar com um
conhecimento muito bom eu deixo vocês
agora com um pequeno vídeo de alguns
pais que são parceiros nessa jornada e
agradeço muito por estar aqui
quanto mais oportunidade ela tiver pra
ter esse contato com pessoas de várias
etnias e países e regiões
contribui com que ela seja uma criança
mais livre
uma criança que pode ter o direito de ir
e vir em qualquer lugar não se sentir
reprimida a diversidade é isso é o
espaço onde esse convívio faz nos faz
crescer nessa direção à direção da
transformação em universidade em vários
aspectos e isso eu acho muito
enriquecedor para a vida desses e nesse
momento de formação dela e lá pra frente
ela cita não há dois anos o torna
enriqueceu do não só pra eles como pra
mim também acabo aprendendo muito com
eles se tiver as culturas e tem que
aprender a respeitar as culturas
religiosas de hábitos de alimentação a
tua verdade não é uma verdade na verdade
pra você
o outro pode ser de outra verdade mais
importante
ao final um é com o apoio da equipe da
escola e dos pais há uma grande né
congregação que vem
[Música]
[Aplausos]